in today's stay well Wednesday we're
talking about different things we can do
to have a safe and healthy holiday Rocky
spoke to Southwest Medical the sponsors
of this segment to get more information
happy holidays I can finally say that
and absolutely at Southwest Medical
would do you want to make sure our
community has a healthy happy holiday
absolutely absolutely uh you know how do
we keep the holidays healthy these days
hey well you know there are quite a few
ways that we can do that so let's talk a
little bit about food uh each year it's
estimated about one in six Americans end
up getting sick from eating contaminated
food and really nobody wants that food
poisoning is no fun you could take a
couple of simple steps to protect your
family's health when you prepare and
serve the holiday meals wash your hands
and work surfaces before cooking
preparing any kind of food and after
eating as well
keep raw meat poultry seafood and eggs
separate during preparation cook food at
the right internal temperature to kill
harmful germs you can find that online
in terms of the correct temperatures for
the type of food that it is that you're
cooking on either the CDC website or
actually a quick Google search usually
it'll solve the problem use food
thermometers they're present at most of
your local grocery stores you can also
pick those up online as well and
definitely don't forget to refrigerate
perishable foods and leftovers within
two hours of buying or cooking and
that's really just on the preparation
side right everybody loves thinking and
talking about the eating it can be
challenging really to eat healthy during
this time of year and I'm not saying
that you necessarily need to deprive
yourself so to speak right but making
sure that you're doing things in
moderation try and make sure that you're
choosing some healthier options such as
things like fresh fruit as a festive
option that also is a sweet substitute
for candy or maybe some of those other
baked goods that we had discussed before
and try and limit also your fats and
your sugary foods and drinks staying
active is also something that could help
keep you healthy during this holiday
season I know for one my family we like
going for a stroll particularly on
Thanksgiving to feel like we've at least
earned our turkey and to add to that
maybe overeating you also might be over
stressing during the holidays make time
to unwind as well a lot of times there's
some stress that's associated maybe with
even prepping and setting up holiday
Gatherings make sure that you build some
time into prepping for things that that
allows you to actually sit and relax and
do things that do cause you to feel a
little more relaxed for stress relief
there are some other things you could do
just kind of physiologically in terms of
taking deep breaths and stretching
meditating something I tell a lot of my
patients to really look at is
potentially doing yoga as well last but
certainly not least
absolutely sleep is incredibly important
and that has to do with I guess that
unwinding right you know average adults
need at least seven hours of sleep a
night and for healthier sleep be
consistent get yourself in a regimen
make sure that you're going to bed at a
set time and kind of trying to wake up
at a set time keep in mind obviously the
standard safety stuff for this time of
year right flu shots are something that
I would still absolutely recommend
getting that is a yearly flu vaccine
it's definitely not too late I know
local pharmacies are giving them I know
that my Clinic's giving them you know if
you haven't gotten a flu shot please go
out and get it because getting the flu
is a miserable thing and also make sure
you get your covid-19 shots boosters or
if even if it's your first series trying
to protect yourself and others is always
a good idea
we want to thank Southwest Medical for
sponsoring this segment you can call
them to get more information at that
phone number
877-5199 or visit their website at
smalv.com for more info